i bet you're wondering why i'm in bed
it's because today's good in five we're
tackling sleep
so
i'm excited because i've got tips and
tricks that you can do in just five
minutes before you lay your head down
for a good night's sleep
first step is something to help you
relax and get you into that
snoozy mood
all right check out this gadget i
haven't tried this yet it's called the
renfo eye massager and it's a device
that you wear on your eyes for five
minutes and it has massage modes
including the sleep mode and it's
supposed to reverse the effects of eye
fatigue to relieve stress and help you
sleep well two of our audience members
anna
and brittany are also wearing one too
all right
let's see oh whoa oh whoa
they're heated
anna yep
what do you think um
oh it's interesting
[Laughter]
britney i can't see anything
but it's very nice
i'm not going to lie
it's kind of hot and sexy
i'm not kidding i'm not getting relaxed
i'm getting totally stimulated
anna brittany what's it doing for you
guys
i honestly don't know
well after i made it overwhelming a
little bit what i love it it's like a
warm cookie on your face
did you say warm cookie
i should also mention i'm hungry
um
huh
never felt a sensation like that i think
i just discovered a new erogenous zone
um i'm excited i want to bring in
clinical psychologist dr shelby harris
who specializes in behavioral sleep
medicine hello
thanks for having me
um
have you ever tried that eye mask i have
not tried that myself it looked like we
had some very varied responses to it
right here i mean whoa
they seemed really different
now you say that achieving good sleep
starts even before bedtime
enlighten me
so i always think about sleep is like an
odd it's not an on off switch it's more
like a dimmer switch so doing a wind
down routine ideally an hour but most of
us don't have an hour so start with five
minutes of relaxation whatever you find
is quieting just do it for five minutes
then move to 10 minutes and really try
to set that stage and the other thing i
also would argue is that a good bedtime
comes with a good morning time so if
you're consistent with the morning
wake-up time every day you get bright
light you move you have a big glass of
water that actually helps to set your
bedtime so you fall asleep a little bit
better as well now how about books
because i tend to like that for me is
the dimmer switch i'll get off tv i'll
get off tech i'll kind of lie in bed and
stare and then i'll put my glasses on
and read
um is that still a stimulation or is
that okay of a transition it really
varies on the person honestly so reading
i think is fantastic for a lot of people
depends some people find reading just
too engrossing for them but for most
people find something that you enjoy
that passes the time and quiets your
brain down but also be careful what
you're reading on right so are we
reading on our little phone
tablet like a lot of patients good i'm
like a huge fan of go old school okay
our next tip is someone to follow
that'll get you that great rem sleep i
want you to check out the couple
who wants to help you relax haley and
grant's sleep granted asmr youtube
channel haley and grant post videos
whispering bedtime stories so that you
can lull into relaxation and peace dr
shelby why is everyone on the asmr
feeder so asmr is a fancy word to fancy
letters for autonomous sensory meridian
response all that really means is that
kind of tingly sensation that you get
down your spine
right so you can get it from videos like
that some people get it from music other
people like i notice sometimes if my
daughter's brushing my hair you get that
just kind of pleasurable relaxation
feeling or a massage anything like that
so although there isn't a lot of
research on it for sleep we do find that
it activates parts of the brain that
promote hormones and neurotransmitters
that are relaxing that induce sleep and
that are pleasure-inducing like oxytocin
dopamine serotonin so it could in theory
help for some people if you have the
occasional bad night here and there well
finally something good to do dr shelby
you have a breathing exercise that we
can all do to quiet our mind so we're
talking about that dimmer switch earlier
what i always do myself is i always just
do a quick three to five minute deep
breathing exercise and i think i'm going
to teach it all to you and i think a lot
of people when they do deep breathing
they're often breathing ah there you go
i have it and i still forget to do it
so when you're learning at the beginning
a lot of people when they do deep
breathing they breathe through their
chest which can make them feel a little
bit more stressed so i have you put one
hand on your chest and one hand on your
belly and i encourage everyone to do
that so you take a deep breath in and
you want this hand to move more and this
should stay still it's hard when you're
standing but ex inhale
exhale
and then you just say relax
inhale
exhale
relax one
inhale
exhale
relax
two and you count up to ten
and back down to one very slowly it's
harder to breathe fast when you're doing
it this way it's easier when you're
lying down like i said um well before we
go let's check in on anna and brittany
ladies how do you feel
um
i don't know
i don't think i would use it
but i get it
right like
that is totally how i feel you summed it
up perfectly brittany i have the exact
opposite
feelings i absolutely love this thing
it's like a warmth
uh towel massage to your face
it's very relaxing
[Music]